now what now what you little ray of
sunshine yeah you purple Delight Violet
Delight I thought we were doing sparkly
Blazers we talked about this yesterday I
cheated shrieked you cheated on me no I
I there's a whole there's there's a
whole story
[Music]
I actually yeah when one me men's
another begins because Nicholas Cage and
you yeah do you know which one I'm
talking about where he looks at you and
he's like this and you're like
when we're High yes yes yeah all over
the Internet we're driving in the car
yeah okay it's a great scene
unbearable weight is one of my favorite
moves I'm very very very proud of that
movie
it's great so do another one do do
another one with him right I know I
would love to
us um okay so something that's
resurfaced is a lot of appearances that
you've done on TV shows Sarah Michelle
Geller posted
on dress which I just found out Sarah
Michelle Geller posted about me yes
I need to get I need to get on the world
wide web
fine I am on Instagram
but I'm I I guess I'm not scrolling
enough
deleted your Twitter are you gonna come
back uh uh I don't think so that's okay
I get why thank you I get why
to say if you could put yourself in any
show or TV show or movie or franchise of
all time which one would you want to do
where's the Sarah Michelle Geller uh
it's on Instagram look I'll show it to
you right now
look
when mother met father is what it says
like uh
what do you remember about that
everything
absolutely everything
and I remember she
she had ice cream and she gave she had
ice cream in her trailer and she she
gave me some she went back to her
trailer she got me some ice cream and
she shared and it was because it was a
night shoot he's in the middle of the
night and we were on the UCLA campus
they hadn't built their college sets yet
and I actually had to
um uh I was doing a play in Long Beach
and I had to miss opening night because
we had to shoot this this this uh
actually this very very short moment
I remember everything I could go on and
on and on I could give you step by step
every detail I had to have lunch in the
vamp mask
in Van face and she was incredibly kind
she taught me how to use a a sandbag to
hit my mark she was the best I have to
let you go but I'm interviewing your
other daughter your other child Bella
Ramsay tomorrow do you have anything
you'd like to ask her or say to her I
will I I we talk almost we communicate
kind of on a daily basis so
um I'll just uh tell her that you you
plant yeah exactly
I'll just be like watch it wear sparkles
foreign